this program is brought to you by Emory
University hi I'm Susan tomasi I'm a
faculty member here at Emory University
and the director of undergraduate
studies for the program in linguistics
i'm also an alumna of emory college
congratulations on your choice to come
to emory university i truly hope your
experience here as is enjoyable
challenging and rewarding his mind was
in order to help you create such a great
experience we're asking you to read and
think about the following article it's
called the Harvard guide to collegiate
happiness and it has some really great
points in it to help any incoming
college students not just those that are
planning on going to Harvard well they
have many great points throughout the
entire article there are a few things
that I really do want to highlight for
you first definitely definitely talk to
your professors most of us aren't as
scary as you think we are and we really
are truly here to help you learn and to
help you manage your way through your
college experience so please do come
talk to us so I can't take a mix of
classes you're coming at Emory because
you're smart and because you're
intellectually curious so try new things
look deeper into something that you've
overlooked before for example if you've
ever SAT and pondered the universe while
looking at the stars go take a
philosophy class or an astronomy class
or both if you've ever been moved by
looking at a piece of art taking our
history class or take something in the
visual arts or try something new simply
because you have no earthly idea what it
is it's a really really great way to go
remember this is your chance to explore
you've already chosen to come to a
school that focuses on the liberal arts
as sets you've already chosen to take a
broad approach to learning so use the
range of courses that we offer to your
advantage we
so many classes available for you and
really you'll be surprised at what you
learn the article will tell you learning
occurs not just inside of the classroom
as much occurs outside of the classroom
as it does with in don't worry however
you don't have to make any decisions yet
you have four years to decide and focus
on and narrow down what courses you're
going to take what extra curriculars are
going to be involved in however we do
want you to start thinking now about the
different ways that you can explore in
the different ways that you can
challenge yourself and please always
remember that people are always here to
help guide you and help you find your
way through your college experience so
good luck have a great summer and we'll
see in the fall the preceding program is
copyrighted by Emory University